whose sales I'm joined by the
international brand expert and former
vice chairman of Saatchi and Saatchi
Rita Clifton and the social media ads at
the IEEE newspaper Felicity more so Rita
this is very witty stuff isn't it but I
mean they've earned the right to be with
you there is nothing sadder than a brand
that actually is trying to kind of be
fun trying to be social and everything
else when they don't get their basic
product and service right so that's the
killer insight here is you've got to be
a really good business with a decent
products in the first place otherwise
save your breath and save you money
Felicity who do you think they're
talking to here is this millennial
customers or a wider audience
well yes I think it does depend on what
you're selling I think for somebody for
example in the news setting like vice
that might be a really good way to
interact with who you want your readers
to be but perhaps not if you're southern
rail and your service is full yes very
well for them well Wendy's sarcastic
put-downs have earned it an 80% increase
in followers during the past year some
companies however have not been so adept
at Twitter campaigns and attempts at
engaging how painfully backfired walkers
recently suffered a backlash after it
tried to promote its brand through
inviting people to post selfies with
Gary Lineker
the feed was inundated as you can see
there with pictures of the former
football star with a range of
unpalatable characters from Stalin to
Jimmy Savile well Rita this is what can
go terribly wrong isn't it I know you've
got to think about the golden rules here
which is number one of course you could
have a great products and service in the
first place secondly you got to produce
great content that people want to share
but thirdly don't ask for it there are
some really really terrible examples
where you know that an investment
company all you know Bank was saying a
asks JPM and of course people will say
things like you know you're stuck in a
room with no key got a paper clip and a
light bulb and everything else now how
do you defraud investors even saintly
Waitrose frankly got it wrong when it
was asking these like shop at Waitrose
because and they were inundated with you
know wall Clarissa's pony won't he'd own
own label
you know straw or hay
whatever it was and and I like going
there because people say things like put
the papaya down Orlando's it has to be
very very careful I mean there's a clue
in the words social you know this for
sharing it's for engaging everything
else but of course it does also suffer
from the downsides of the social
situations which is that you can lose
friends and not influence people pretty
quickly too you know Felicity you
touched on southern rail just now where
they have the fifteen-year-old intern
the other day them but that was their
best publicity for me but can you
imagine if they've been really sassy
and when people were striking it might
have worked for them they might have
said oh I'm sorry that we want fair pay
that that could have gone viral but also
they could have also it could backfire
very badly I think it depends on and I
think also what's interesting is I'm
very interested to see how it working at
British contacts because Wendy's is
American there's a bit of sass going
around some BBC three I think do it
quite well and I think with younger
audiences they quite like it because
they understand that it's playful yeah
what I mean old of customers might find
it a bit disrespectful almost Martyn
though well I can do but I mean if you
think about the profile of people who
are on social media I mean the vast
majority of young people of course are
on social media but they spend a lot of
their life on social media now clearly
Internet users I mean the majority of
them are using social media but it does
go down by age groups so you've got to
make sure you're age-appropriate that
your brand appropriate that your message
appropriate but at the end of the day
you've got to be a really really good
business where your own staff care about
you they're prepared to say nice things
about you this is a great way of getting
you know brand performance really really
quickly on a low budget if you are
really good because people share that
story if you're rubbish sadly people
share that story as well if you ask for
it I'm afraid that's going to kind of
get around pretty pretty quickly and
virally - yeah maybe interested sorry
Felicity I was gonna say I think
sometimes it's much more fun as a social
media medicine I used to work at BBC
News be if you can reply to people and
the BBC or radio one you were a bit
you've got your hands tied behind your
back a little bit but we used to get
sort of 45 year old men tweeting at her
saying like oh I don't like one
rection like bring Chris Moyles back and
it's like maybe you should just change
radio station yeah you have to be very
careful about that one certainly looking
as though you're trying to groove it up
down with the kids really really bad
news you've got to make sure you get the
message right you're gonna make sure
that you get your offers right and of
course you've got to make sure you get
the language right - and I mentioned
Waitrose earlier they were great they
came out and said we enjoyed or we
enjoyed reading all these jokes - so
they they got themselves in on the joke
even though they actually made a mistake
in the first place so you can recover
from these situations but not if you are
a bad business or a rubbish brand very
briefly Felicity who do you think has
been the best example lately I think
Greg's is really good I think they sort
of hit it just about right and they're
trying to be nice and be in on the joke
a little bit perhaps like a Nando's like
cheeky Nando's and all of that going
around and they tweeted Sheeran that
they're trying to sort of get in with
that kind of thing and they reply to
people I think also a virgin have been
quite good I know somebody tweeted at
them saying and oh there's no toilet
roll okay leave it I'm afraid misty or
leave it